scoot is presenting its new octavia
station wagon the combi at Lake chiemsee
Bavaria the sales figures prove this is
one of the most popular station wagons
in Europe Scott is introducing the
latest model Octavia to increase its
market share in Western Europe dr.
Schmidt no fee for scooters Hammond
Schmidt explains that the Octavia
station wagon accounts for over one
third of sales and the company hopes to
expand the share the station wagon is a
key factor there's also a sedan version
of course but the station wagon is
especially important because it makes up
some ninety percent of octavia sales in
Germany Octavia for careful that
reflects approximately the percentage of
the overall sales sometimes it didn't
balloon Sigmund for the length of four
metres 66 the wagon is as robust as any
skoda the transmission and steering are
tight and handling is good
via testing you deny our test driver
Chris took out the 1.6 litre
turbocharged direct-injection version
listed at twenty thousand seven hundred
forty euros the smallest
gasoline-powered version starts at
sixteen thousand six hundred forty euros
a tad in rated consumption of 3.8 liters
per 100 kilometers at an official 99
grams of co2 per kilometer the emissions
are quite acceptable price is too
the station wagons front is identical
with the sedans the hood the grill and
the headlights everything
the line sweep dynamically from the
front to rear windows
but the rear can seem a bit off-putting
parking sensors are standard
the extreme glowstick off chris is
impressed by the Octavia station wagons
extremely large cargo space he says he'd
fitted to the 610 litres space twice
over now this little lever turns the 610
litres into 1740 that's about eighty
five litres more than its predecessor
the interior has many convenient details
in store the electronically adjustable
seats for instance with a memory for
personalized sitting positions
in the center console are the radio and
several assist systems including of
course parking assist
skoda has aggressive plans for the
market with several more models soon to
be released
yazoo kada and fo em on Schmidt's oscoda
is in a phase of product fireworks that
began in the middle of last year the
city go is an entirely new model for a
whole new segment a variation of the ufe
is the space back Skuta will be face
lifting the superb before the end of the
year and the yeti by early next year in
2014 it's the Fabia stern so by the end
of next year the entire range of models
will have been updated festivals will
complete them were dead pilot wouldn't
honor at sources on to sum up the
Octavia station wagon chris has no
complaints whatsoever about the driving
qualities that drive smoothly and
pleasantly with the consumption of just
3.8 liters per hundred kilometers it's a
car for hauling loads and saving fuel a
car worthy of its predecessors